they do they have amazing pies careful
around your eyes there is there be
careful around your eyes
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Zac Efron he's
an actor you know from films like the
greatest showman neighbors and Ted Bundy
extremely wicked he also has a YouTube
channel with a casual million plus subs
as well as a brand new series on the way
it's called killing Zac Efron it's set
to hit kwibi this spring
Zac Efron welcome to the show thanks for
having me man that was awesome good
intro I know that you're an adventurous
eater
how are you around spicy food something
happened when I was traveling
internationally I just I thought I could
eat spicy food I thought it was a
healthy food it's healthy spicy food
either a good one even but I went it
somewhere to a couple countries that
really put a lot of spice into their
food and learn to respect it yeah I
almost died and then like came back and
I have a healthy respect now for for
sauce
[Music]
have you going already she's diving
right in those delicious
how can a piece of cake
so I'm watching your new quip you showed
killing Zac Ephron it's clear that you
have an affinity for extreme situations
like going deep into these dangerous
jungle to hunt crocodiles is part of the
appeal of shooting in these remote
locations is that there are thousands of
miles away from Hollywood like are you
kind of interested in the fact that
you're kind of a escaping the Hollywood
machine even though you're obviously
bringing cameras along for the journey
that's really it's an interesting that
you put it that way yes
skate like partly I call it escaping I
think it definitely is escaping but
going on trips like on the weekend going
into the woods backpacking camping rock
climbing these things are like very
engrained in Who I am as a person so
that's my therapy I do that to get away
and to sort of have some sort of
equilibrium helps me think and process I
have no trouble sleeping when I'm
camping like I can go out there and
reset for a weekend and I'll come back
and I'll help me struggle city sleeping
in LA no matter where I am but it's fun
to get out there it's fun to bring
friends so yeah
get outside so that's a prescription
we are should we add some is that how
should we do people do that or these
like I'll see older this is an aesthetic
thing well uh it's happened once before
Shia LaBeouf came in here and he
actually drives it up yeah so play that
however you want [ __ ] it let's go all
right how do you tell how do you tell
how hot it's gonna be by eating it okay
[Music]
[Music]
well at least if I'm trying I'm trying
out the pouring method it's on the early
side of this that's smart
hmm
it's on your YouTube channel you have
this show gym time where you workout
with everyone from NFL stars to
Victoria's Secret models having stepped
into the world of so many different
Fitness obsessives is their kind of
training that you respect the most on a
sheer grit level that's a good question
um for me athletes are like movie stars
I would say you know it's when I get to
meet where I hang out with somebody
who's been inspiration to me through
whatever their art or craft is that's
really fun and if they want to train
with me unreal
I'm getting this to peek behind the
curtain can sort of just have fun with
them and see them in their element
because that's all they do is they train
and some of them are savage I'm always
amazed by certain actors abilities to
transform their bodies based on the
requirements of whatever character
they're playing from movie to movie
definitely what's the difference and how
you and your trainer might approach
plane like a Baywatch lifeguard versus
playing like Ted Bundy oh man another
great question that was actually a
really important time to do pay watch
cuz I realized that like when I was done
with that movie I don't ever want to be
in that good of shape again really it's
like it's I was so it was so art you're
working with almost no wiggle room right
you've got things like water under your
skin that you're worrying about like
making your six pack into a four pack
[ __ ] like that that's just like not it's
just stupid no it's not it's just not
real I'm like I'm happy that that it
worked I'm happy that it got me through
it I may do it again if it was something
worthwhile but we'll wait till it gets
to that I don't need to I'm good take
care of your heart take care of your
brain you're good
[Music]
oh sure let me hit that he's like yeah
no I don't want to how many of these
shows have you done this is uh believe
it or not Season eleven approaching 200
episodes set across from 200 famous
people doing this that's awesome
man that's so cool that's I feel like I
knew it was gonna be a high number but
200 just of course you don't want to
pour out any extra sauce no but you know
what I like I like the new experience
you know that's what I think is funny
about this is that in the hundreds of
times that we've done it there have been
so many different ways that it's
approached cool you know it is a good
this whole setup is just money man like
this is why you go out to eat wings so
you can be with your homies man this is
awesome so I'm fascinated by your signed
baseball collection which isn't just
something that you spent millions of
dollars on it's something that dates
back to you being a little kid chasing
down homerun balls at Giants games
that's exactly right
do you have a favorite story or a
baseball that to you is like a crown
jewel in the collection Dusty Baker the
coach of the Giants at the time he drove
by and he was on a motorcycle so he
didn't have a window he could roll up so
he saw like there was a couple people
waiting for him I ran up with a baseball
and I was like we signed on this you
know I had like a blue pen and the sweet
spot of a brand new ball and I showed it
to him and dusty was like oh I can't
right now I got to go to church and that
just me it's usually like don't have
time right he's like I'll be back in 30
minutes he left and I thought I was
never gonna see him again 45 minutes
later the motorcycle came roaring in and
I was like no way and he literally
pointed right at me he's like come over
here and I walked over he's like you
still got that ball I was like yeah
thank you sir somebody signed it so that
one meant a lot to me just cuz Dusty
Baker like doubled back from church who
knows what he did but it was pretty
awesome it was really cool that I was
like I'd like bleached hair I was a
little kid just yeah awesome while
filming Charlie st. cloud did you pick
up anything interesting when you were
working alongside Atlanta Braves
pitching coach Roger McDowell
oh my gosh man blast from the past we
had to play catch but I could play catch
at that point I played baseball grown-up
so which is good cuz sometimes in the
movies you never know like sometimes
your watch is why he was there cuz
there's a couple of those like what's
the one I'm thinking of War of the
Worlds moments look like
[Music]
I like mustard I like mustard a lot so
as you mentioned you're a seasoned
traveler criss crossing across the globe
your own adventures and then of course
even your movie roles if you could spend
one month surfing anywhere where would
you go mm probably Costa Rica I think
Bali's pretty red ball these are awesome
right now like um I think I just have so
many friends in Costa Rica that that
would be this is just got hot do you
have a favorite golf course in Hawaii
there's just insane golf last time only
coughing I went with uh I should not
touch my eyes right that's that's anyone
done that uh I would say in about forty
five percent of the episodes really well
it's hard no way man oh geez I'm so
happy I just touched my nose because I
can feel it yeah but the eyes because
the water so you'll think to yourself oh
I just I just gotta wipe my eye but then
you have sauce of the cross-pollination
they're late you're late your eyeballs
on fire oh man I'm ready for the next
one I'm ready for the next one I said
it's Costa Rica and what's and what was
the next one who favorite golf course I
don't know there's one in Valencia I
used to sneak onto the links that's my
favorite one all right great memories
let's go on to los calientes Rojo here
oh those calientes real cool
[Music]
first we feast man it's a cool name so
Zack we have a recurrence segment on our
show called explain that Graham where we
do a deep dive on our guest Instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
context so we'll put it up here on the
monitor and then you just tell us the
bigger story okay
the major form is oh yeah they're not
from mine like for example man that's
all my oh that's great
here you are Jim Gary's pinching your
nipple it seems like an image that
requires more explanation I went to
Hawaii I was I was staying with my
friend Kenny Ortega he directed High
School Musical this is a couple years
after and he said you want to I'm
friends with Jim Carrey you want to go
to his house so we walked down the beach
and there was this really cool Bush sort
of up against the beach it was like
along the beach and it was like a berm
when we walked like into it and it
formed a tunnel and I had never really
been in a plant tunnel before so but it
was the path from the beach we walked
through it and I see Kenny like hey and
then I looked at the second story and
unlike the second story of the building
[Music]
Jim Carrey was there just standing on
the balcony he was like oh it was really
like Ace Ventura pet detective and
that's one of my favorite movies growing
up so it was pretty cool he's a very
nice guy and one of my frickin heroes so
that's it that's the explanation behind
that photo I don't know why I said my
nipple this is your eggs big bite Martin
garrix yeah big friend of the program we
call big bite Martin garrix so what
really was yeah and then is this average
with the bites he's a savage with the
bites
I met him totally on accident that night
we was walking down the street in
Amsterdam and I see of all things in
Amsterdam a crowd of like video cameras
what looked like to me to be like TMZ or
foot photographer type people my lips
and then and then suddenly someone's
tapping me on the shoulder and I'm pay
its the person tapping he was like hey
man what's up and I was looking it was
Martin and he's like I'm from here dude
it's my birthday like tomorrow what do
you want to come to a concert and I was
like yeah sure so I quit what I
I went to hang out with Martin he like
organized his setlist and I was just
chilling watching him and then next
thing I know I was up on stage and like
that that little booth he's out with the
DJ booth I was like underneath it for a
whole set it's just like down below and
I was just like what's going on and he's
like this is sick right I'm like yeah it
was really funny
all right next up this is very uh
mentor-mentee looking to me actually it
was really cool about that night and
this kind of sticks in my mind is like
we weren't talking at that point and
then I was just kind of gonna wait for
him and sure enough he like had his hat
down low and when the ball went to the
other side he was like hey man do you
want to like go get breakfast tomorrow
and I was like yeah dude so he like gave
me he wrote my phone number down and
then handed it to me while the other
team was scoring and nobody saw and I
took it and he cooked me breakfast the
next day at his house would he cook up
he cooked he actually he cooked waffles
and then he burnt those and then he made
pancakes it was awesome I don't know I
had a billion questions for him at that
point definitely dealing with too much
paparazzi presents in my life and like
sitting next to Leo I was just like dude
how do you how have you handled this for
so long he was like frankly you're
getting in a little bit different you
know it's a little bit yeah didn't you
like look at the monitors and be like
yeah well I've never had that's so like
um damn how do you know who'd you talk
to you Jesus I really think my publicist
knows this Jesus man who'd you talk to
you do you know other [ __ ] I'm gonna
say it now [ __ ] sorry
screw it I'm gonna say it now uh I
pulled up and lick these some cars
followed me this was just a normal
routine it's just like leave my driveway
and like ten cars would follow
he was like yeah there's never this many
cars here and he was like that's insane
dude and I saw in his eyes a little bit
of like the feeling that I consistently
was having all the time which was just
like stress and anxiety and he was like
don't worry about it man it's it's your
year good and I really appreciate that
he's like that time you know
you feel good about it help me a little
bit so that's the biggest hand you can
extend I feel like in Hollywood is
looking out for someone younger so rock
on leo thank you buddy
I just have a man let's have a feeling
oh yeah
well that's a good system for years as
better remember hooking half split numb
[Music]
so the paparazzi talk was actually a
rather poetic segue into this question
because over the years we've had some
incredible paparazzi evasion techniques
discussed on this show when you think on
your own experiences is there a maneuver
that you've done to evade the paps that
over the years may be a story that
you're particularly proud of that one's
not for almost like a two or three year
period of my life I drove through
various Lots pulling in on one side of
Warner Brothers or Universal just going
in one of their ten entrances and then I
don't know staying in there for 15
minutes and leaving through one and
trying to catch him not looking and then
if that didn't work I would have to go
back and go somewhere else a lot of
people they don't really believe you or
they think like just just live your life
that's movie star problems yes yeah
you're talking to such high-class
problems and we are yeah it's it's a
ridiculous thing and it feels stupid to
complain about and like part of me
doesn't even want us to do it but since
this is the forum for stories
my dad was skeptical about the paparazzi
so we pulled out he was driving my
little brothers in the car and they
start following us and I was like
they're definitely following and he's
like yeah right and I said it was the
car behind us like a you know a 4runner
a beige 4runner and he's like yeah so
like yeah well that's the car that
always follows me behind that is gonna
be a you know an su to another this SUV
a GMC something and and he was like
started to realize that I was right and
he just didn't want to accept it he just
couldn't accept it so we drove to the
Catalina Expressway one by one with him
realizing the amount of cars and the
building anger inside of him was just
hilarious he was like this legal this
this should be I can't that guy you told
me that guy right you hey you and I'm
just like dad you need to relax man
I can chill and he's like this happens
all the time to you I can't believe this
is this is insane
I don't even really believe it I don't
even think that's right that guy's not
he has a camera oh my god he's shooting
us what is it I'm like daddy you're
giving him exactly what he wants Manning
that's a show
[Music]
I've definitely like had weed maybe
stargazer trip I'm not probably not
gonna do too much I assume this has got
to be that we're getting up to a serious
is it okay I've been warned
oh I can feel it already that's the
smell this is snow
[Music]
hmm is it true that Tom Cruise gave you
an impromptu tour of his motorcycle
hangar yeah man those rap red Ducati Tom
Cruise pulls up in the red Ducati
I'm with he had a helmet I think he he
pulled up if there was I wasn't a hanger
it was kind of like this and like yeah
they were air he had air like legit
airplanes all parked in there
he flies by on a red Ducati just like in
mi3 like I did I hear it and it's just
like flying so cool I hope that's him he
doubles back around Tom Cruise and he
pulls in and he got got off the bike but
then I think he left the bike running a
little bit because the as soon as you
went to get off it you like swung his
leg over and the bike kind of sketched
forward and he went like whoa and then
it stopped again and so I walked forward
and I was gonna shake his hand he went
to get off again and it revved up again
and he went a little further forward
like starting up it was just it was a
funny moment mm-hmm I'm still super
super cool what's the backstory on
breaking your hand and neighbors as I
understand it you had to get an
emergency surgery to keep from derail in
the film that's a bit of a build up
that's that that's what's that said no
all right that's edit not built-up
sounds leo I broke his hand and then
didn't go to the hospital like saved the
booty man you said something about how
actors will often look for excuses not
to do they're very easy job yes that's
yeah I'm not the opposite man I'm a
workhorse I like it man that's just
leaders that one's a leader man just you
wait I'm not gonna touch it not touching
it
everyone everybody's laughing right now
my nose be running you
to bomb beyond and sander figure I'll
pop the top and tell the wheels fall off
and tell them walking around these guys
are all laughing is this a secret sauce
everybody knows about this one is this
where the wheels fall off the bombs got
something stuck in it stop let's go it's
not make new make sense yeah I like to
dive into that one at the same time as
the guest so that we start to oh yeah
now we're not in our diving it whoo
sever that's a good one I heard you say
that if you weren't an actor you'd be a
chef what what does zac efron restaurant
look like would it be you know global
flavors inspired by your travels or
would it be like a gym rat fuel up
station with like steamed brown rice and
unseasoned chicken breast oh man you
know what I really like food I've
traveled to places based on some of the
destinations that I'm going to eat at oh
and do people I'm gonna cry man these
are see you cried a little bit just here
at the table
come on see we talk about anything it
seems like I'm gonna be emotional about
everybody's so knowingly looking in
there and that's very um do you have an
all-time favorite food city oh man
Chicago is great Chicago has to shout
out Chicago yeah man absolutely shut
down boy that's right all my friends are
in Chicago Chicago Chicago ins targets
Chicago my sand away Obispo mm-hmm have
you ever been really over and a more
specifically hmm yeah have you ever been
to that apple farm in yeah we've got a
tremendous like pies and [ __ ] they do
they have amazing pies careful around
your eyes there is there careful around
your eyes thanks we're looking out for
each other here actually I stayed at
that wheel house one you know like
they're big into the like if you can get
one of you houses yeah we stayed there
yeah that's awesome that's my heart that
I was just there the other day I did it
like each cleanup in Morro Bay which was
pretty close by when I stopped back at
AG and like was at a gas station and I
just I was always around growing up but
it looked way nicer and I pulled in in
this truck saw me with my window rolled
I was in the backseat this car this guy
saw me he was like older than me
you know he's older than both of us and
he was like Zac Efron I like looked at
him reflexively I was like what's up and
he goes hey JEE and I was like AG he's
like yeah and then like all four windows
rolled down and like four guys what a ga
ga gee so I don't know why but I'm
starting to feel like a hometown hero
I want to put a lot of happy
[Music]
[Music]
our mom's still the most intense and
Savage fans to meet in the wild yeah how
do you do that tell you that [ __ ] you
know what I think moms are a little bit
less they have less of a guard up in a
good way
dad's there's this weird thing of like
we're all men here right so it's like
they don't know if they want to admit it
or not and for the longest time a lot of
guys would be like you know what and
then like later in the same night I
would see that person and they would be
like little drunk singing a high school
musical song I'm like you could just
tell me when I walked you know Thanks
what's the biggest difference between
catching a football from Drew Brees and
then just like playing catch with your
brother on the beach like is the
rotation is there something about it
that snaps different 100% when drew
brees when Drew Brees goes and like
throws a pass first of all he could be
like 50 yards away and when it comes out
to you just see a tight circle that's
like not even visiting looking at
spinning it just looks like it's
vibrating or wobbling when as soon as he
like lazily throws it it's in your face
and you're catching it and it's like
going by you've got to hang on to that
thing you got to really have that
diamond shape in your hand so you won't
catch it all right Zach Efron all right
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
we don't everyone makes it to the over
this bar this is rarified air okay good
Zach with all the sauces all over the
plate it's been quite the journey you
don't have to I was gonna it feels that
way anyway oh yeah it's a rarefied
journey even without this the last dab I
also know we named that oh man here we
go no cap no cap your cap and all right
we got a fair bit on there let's get it
cheers let's get it cheers a quarter
right don't go soft man stay hard stay
hard stay hard
[Music]
okay Zach here we are end of the line
and only one more hurdle in your way and
we're throwing it back here on Wayne ten
okay
in the beginning of your career you
couldn't get through an interview
without a host or junket creature giving
you a basketball and asking you to do
some sort of tricks yeah Dom balmy so
here what you want me to do tricks like
we're promoting seventeen again cool
there's so much sauce on my hands
you know it's easy to do don't use when
you're just promoting seventeen again
not you know with a billion Scoville
running through you is that how many
scovilles is in me and hot sauce all
over your hands it might not be so easy
I think no matter what's pretty easy
[Music]
there's sauce everywhere watch is gonna
knock ya everything are the whip action
on the ball very good and look look at
you Zac Efron's funding through the hot
ones gauntlet still spinning that ball
because you sound got it still seventeen
baby and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera or this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life what's up I'm Zack
I love long walks on the beach and I had
enough spicy food to last a lifetime
check out my new show on kwibi it's
called killing Zac Efron we getting some
crazy high jinks in that show this is
ridiculous man it's gonna be one of the
funniest like meme [ __ ] forever
crying right now okay guys all over we
chased off the taste buds way to go
sauce 1/3 peg only meatless calm Ketchum
on hot ones the game show
[Music]